Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Efendim merhaba.
Bundan çok seneler önce
Ajda Pekkan'ın bir şarkısı vardı:
"Bir anda değişti her şey,
bir anda değişti dünyam,
bir anda değiştim ben"
diye devam eden,
çok az kimsenin anımsadığı bir şarkı.
Ne kadar bir an?
Göz açıp kapayıncaya
kadar herhâlde, değil mi?
Ne kadar zamanda gözümüzü
açıp kapatıyoruz derseniz eğer,
0-3 ile 0-4 saniye sürüyor
bir göz açıp kapamak
ve bir dakika içerisinde de,
kaç defa gözümüzü açıp
kapattığımızı biliyoruz.
Aşağı yukarı, en az beş defa.
Tabii gözümüze bir şey
kaçmadığı takdirde.
Şimdi şöyle bir hesap yapmak
mümkün, basit bir hesap,
60 yıllık bir zaman dilimi içerisinde
1 ile 1,5 milyar kez
gözümüzü açıp kapatıyoruz.
Bunların arasında, benim yaşamımda,
10 kez göz açıp kapatıncaya kadar
geçen süre var, yani 10 an var.
Şimdi Ajda Pekkan'ın bu
"Bir anda değişti her şey,
bir anda değişti dünyam," dediği
mutlaka ilk bakışta aşktı.
Bugün hepinizin sevgililer gününü de
kutluyorum bu vesileyle.
Şimdi benimkisi ilk bakışta
aşklarla ilgili değil,
benimkisi sadece meslek yaşamımla ilgili,
kendi kariyerimle ilgili 10 an.
Bugün onları sizle paylaşmak istiyorum
ve bir anın ne kadar önemli olduğunu
ve bir insanın hayatını
nasıl değiştirebildiğini görmek için
ilginç örneklerdir diye düşünüyorum.
Şimdi ben lisede
çok çalışkan bir öğrenciydim
ve her sınavda en son çıkan öğrenciydim.
Kağıdımı böyle çabuk vermezdim,
nitekim aynı şekilde,
üniversite giriş sınavında da
kağıdımı en son verdiğimi
zannederek çıktım.
Annem ve anneannem
- burada gördüğünüz annem -
ve onun annesi, bütün büyük sınavlarımda
dışarıda, kapının dışında beni
beklerlerdi, pek heyecanlı insanlardı.
Dolayısıyla o gün de
böyle üniversite giriş
imtihanından çıktığımda
bir bahçeye çıkılıyordu.
Şimdi bu 10 anın her birini aslında
o kadar ayrıntılı hatırlıyorum ki
bu size anlattığım mesela 1968'de,
yani bundan 50 yıl önceki bir an.
Bahçenin büyüklüğünden ışığa,
güneşin nereden geldiğine varıncaya kadar
bir sürü şey hatırlıyorum.
Bu 10 anla ilgili mekânın
bırakın sadece nasıl bir yer olduğunu,
ortamın kokusunu dahi hatırlıyorum.
Şimdi işte bu hayatımı değiştiren
ilk anlardan bir tanesi,
bir sayfayı çevirmeyi unuttuğum bir an.
Yani bir sayfa çevirmemişim.
Nedir çevirmediğim sayfa?
Şöyle, dışarı çıktığımda
benden başka kimse yoktu.
Bahçenin bir tarafında annem
ve anneannem vardı,
onlardan da başka kimse yok etrafta.
Bunun üzerine böyle
bir kâbus gibi tuhaf bir durum.
Dediler ki, "Niçin çıktın?"
Dedim ki, "Bitti. Onun için çıktım."
Aradan böyle bir 10 dakika sonra ancak
başka öğrenciler çıkmaya başladılar
ve aralarında benim Alman Lisesi'nden de
bazı tanıdıklarım vardı, yanıma geldiler.
Birtakım şeyler söylüyorlar,
diyorlar ki mesela,
"O hücre zarıyla ilgili olan
soruya ne cevap verdin?"
Ben diyorum ki,
"Öyle bir soru yoktu ki!"
Sonra başka biri geliyor, o da diyor ki,
yine öyle biyoloji ile ilgili
bir şeyler soruyorlar.
Ben o soruların hiçbirini görmemişim
çünkü o bir anda o sayfayı çevirmemişim
ve altta olan o ince yazıyı,
"Şimdi matematik bölümü
bitti, sayfayı çevirin"
diyen satırı okumadığım için
biyoloji sorularının hiçbirine
cevap vermeden çıktım.
Dolayısıyla tabii hiçbir
üniversiteye de giremedim
ve beni bir özel üniversiteye yazdırdılar,
ülkemizin ilk özel üniversitesiydi,
Galatasaray'ın Kimya bölümü.
Zaten kimya okumamı
kararlaştırmıştı aile.
Ben aslında mimar olmak istiyordum
ama ailemiz öyle istediği için
çünkü annemin bir laboratuvarı vardı,
o laboratuvarın başına geçmem için
biyokimya uzmanı olmam gerekiyordu.
Biyokimya uzmanı olabilmek için de
ya tıp ya kimya okumak gerekiyordu.
Daha kısa bir yol olduğu için
kimyayı tercih ettiler
ve ben de onların istediğini
yaptım ve Kimya fakültesi dedik.
Tabii devlet üniversitesine giremeyince
beni Galatasaray özel Kimyaya yazdırdılar.
Bir 6 ay kadar oraya devam ettim,
daha sonra bunlar yine geldi
annem ile anneannem, dediler ki:
"Senin naklini yaptırdık
İstanbul Üniversitesi'ne.
Hayırdır, dedim, ben buradan memnunum.
Şişli'de oturuyoruz zaten, okul da yakın.
Gidip geliyorum.
Dediler ki, "Olmaz, devlet üniversitesine
yedeklerden sıra sana geldi."
Bunun üzerine Kimya
fakültesine girdim, onu bitirdim.
Sonra da Cerrahpaşa Tıp Fakültesi
Biyokimya ana bilim dalında -
o zamanlar adı kürsüydü -
Biyokimya uzmanlığı yapmaya başladık
ve maksat biyokimya uzmanı olup
annemin laboratuvarında çalışmaktı.
Almanca bildiğim için
beni bir nefroloji kongresinde
tercüman olarak
görevlendirdiler üniversitede
ve bu nefroloji kongresi sırasında bir an,
şu resimde gördüğünüz kişiye,
herhangi bir şey içmek ister
misiniz diye sordum.
Bu bir Alman, döndü bana,
işte herhâlde kola ya da
gazoz gibi bir şey söyledi.
Ama ondan sonra da herhâlde
canı çok sıkılıyormuş ki,
"Ne yapıyorsun, ne ediyorsun?" diye sordu
ve "Almanya'da çalışmak
ister misin?" dedi.
Bir anda evet dedim.
Hâlbuki artık o tarihte evliydim
ve küçük bir çocuğum da vardı.
Fakat öyle bir andı ki bu,
hayatımın değişebileceğini
herhâlde hissettim,
ne olduğunu bilemiyorum ve evet dedim.
İşte bu kişi, Profesör Tourav,
meğerse Almanya'da
çok önemli bir bilim insanı,
bir fizyolog, profesör
ve DAAD denen bir burs
sisteminin de yönetim kurulunda
ve bana bir ay içerisinde bir
Alman Akademisyenler Bursu çıkarttılar
ve ben kendimi Almanya'da buldum.
Orada doktora çalışmama
başlama fırsatını yakaladım.
Bu, hayatımın önemli bir anıydı
ve de buradan yaklaşık 35-40 yıl
öncesinden söz ediyoruz artık.
Fakat ilginç olan bir başka an var.
O sırada Cerrahpaşa Tıp Fakültesi'nde
yine biyokimyada tabii ki
kariyerime devam ederken
bir gün merdivenlerde,
bahçenin merdivenlerinde,
ben iki basamak aşağıda,
şurada gördüğünüz, toprağı bol olsun,
Profesör Doktor Alaaddin Akçasu.
Çok önemli bir farmakoloji hocamız,
o da benden iki basamak yukarıda.
Boyu çok kısaydı, dolayısıyla biz aynı
boydaydık o basamak farkına rağmen.
Göz gözeydik böyle.
Bana dedi ki,
"Ne işin var bu biyokimyada?"
Nasıl, dedim, ne işim var?
Biyokimya dedi, çok para ister,
memleketin parası yok.
Tüp alacak paramız yok.
Hâlbuki senin bu bilginle,
yani hem kimya hem biyokimya bilginle
adli tıpta çok iş yapabilirsin.
Cebinden küçük bir şey çıkarttı;
yeşil, böyle katı bir plaka.
Meğerse esrarmış, onun ne
olduğunu daha sonra anladım tabii.
Bak, dedi, bunun ne olduğunu
Türkiye ayırt edemiyor.
Şurada bir ince tabakaya
kromatografisini yap.
Peki dedim, aldım
ve o anda bana dedi ki,
"Adli tıpta çalışacaksın,
biyokimyayı bırak!"
Peki, dedim.
Alaaddin Akçasu'nın bu önerisini o
tarihten bu tarihe yürütüyorum.
Hâlbuki adli tıp kurumunun başkanı
babamdı, Profesör Doktor Şemsi Gök
ve bir gün bile bana adli tıpla
ilgili bir iş yapmam için
herhangi bir öneride bulunmamıştı
çünkü benim kaderim
biyokimya üzerine gidiyordu.
Hiç ilgisiz, ailemizin çok dışında birisi,
Alaaddin Akçasu'nun sayesinde birdenbire
babamla birlikte çalışmaya başladım.
Çok yol aldık, çok yeni şeyler yaptık.
Türkiye için büyük adımlar attık
ama ben kimya dairesinin
başkanı olduğum bir noktada--
ki 12 yıl orada başkanlığım var--
bir de baktım ki, usta çırak usulü
insanlar bir şeyler yapıyorlar.
Türkiye'nin bütün uyuşturucusunu,
bütün toksikolojik analizini,
yani zehirlenmeleri, her türlü
gıdasının analizini orada yapıyoruz.
Ama usta çırak usulü
bir öğrenim biçimi var,
bu da çağa hiç uymayan bir yaklaşım.
Nasıl o Alaaddin Akçasu'nun
bana vermiş olduğu o yeşil plakanın,
Türkiye o tarihte kına mı, esrar mı
olduğunu ayırt edemiyor ise,
benzer şekilde bir sürü
şeyi de hiç yapamıyorduk,
sene 80'lerdi.
Almanya'da bir kongrede bir başka an.
Bu kongre bir üniversitenin
bahçesinde kurulan
büyük bir çadırda öğle yemekleri veriyor.
Bu yemek çadırının kuyruğundayız.
Önümde benim iki mislim büyüklüğünde,
üç mislim genişliğinde bu kişi duruyor.
Bu kuyrukta arka arkayayız,
devamlı homurdanıyor.
Hep bir şikayetçi ama ne olduğunu
anlamak mümkün değil.
Sonunda ben dayanamadım,
"Affedersiniz, yardımcı
olabilir miyim?" dedim.
Tabii Almanca bildiğim için,
belki dedim ki yani bununla--
bu belli bir Almanca da bilmiyor,
zaten Amerikalı olduğu da ortaya çıktı.
Dedim ki, "Bir sıkıntınız
varsa halledelim."
Hep söyleniyor, diyor ki,
"Devamlı bu lahanalar, bu sosisler,
bilmem ne, doğru dürüst bir yemek yok."
Tabii belli çok iyi yemek yediği!
Ondan sonra dedim ki,
"Bir şeyler buluruz belki size."
Böyle bir sempati gösterdim ona.
Neyse işte o yine de o sosise
ve lahanaya razı geldi o öğlen.
Ama o kuyruktayken,
birdenbire bana dedi ki:
"Amerika'ya gelmek ister misin?"
Evet, dedim.
Bir hayli büyümüş bir çocuğum
var tabii ki o tarihte,
bir de güzel bir işim var, çalışıyorum da.
Kim olduğunu bile bilmiyorum!
Adam bana Amerika'ya gelir misin, diyor.
Peki, diyorum ben
ve meğerse bu da,
Amerika'nın en büyük
kriminal laboratuvarı olan
Los Angeles Şerif Kriminal
Dairesi'nin başkanıymış.
Dünya'nın en büyük
laboratuvarını yöneten bir adam.
Aynı zamanda, çok önemli
bir meslek derneğimizin de başkanı,
dergi editörleri, vesaire çıktı.
Bu adam benim için bir mektup yazdı.
Ben o mektupla
"Humphrey Fellowship" denen
çok önemli bir Amerikan başkanlık
bursunu, bir yıllık bir bursu alabildim.
Bir yıl boyunca Amerika'nın bütün
kriminal laboratuvarlarını dolaştım
habire onun adıyla.
Şimdi bu haftasonu yine
onun adını kullanarak
12 kişi Üsküdar Üniversitesi'nden
Amerika'ya bir kongreye gidiyoruz
ve onu da ziyaret edeceğiz Los Angeles'ta.
Tabii şimdi emekli oldu
ama hâlâ bu sektörün,
yani adli bilimler sektörünün
duayenlerinden bir tanesi Barry Fisher.
Barry Fisher, o da bir kimyacı.
O da bir göçmen ailenin çocuğu olarak
Amerika'da kendisine yer bulmuş birisi.
Bir anda söylenen bu
Amerika teklifinin akabinde
başka bir anda,
birçoğunuzun mutlaka
resmini görünce tanıyacağı
Ertuğrul Özkök bana bir gece telefon etti.
İşte çalışıyordum,
"Gazeteye yazar mısın?" dedi.
Hayatımda bir gazete makalesi yazmamıştım.
Herhangi bir kitap da yazmamıştım,
yani böyle hayal üzerine bir şey.
Sadece bilimsel yayın
yapıyorduk o tarihe kadar.
Yazarım dedim, bir anda
ve 5 yıl boyunca Hürriyet gazetesinde
her pazar tam sayfa
"Delil Avcısı" diye bir sayfada,
gerçek suç öyküleri yazdım.
Gene bir gece, çalışıyorum, bir telefon.
Ben Dışişleri Bakanlığı'ndan birisi.
Dedi ki, "Hocam, çok önemli
bir görev var Birleşmiş Milletler'de.
Bu görev için bu akşam mutlaka
bir aday bildirmesi lazım Türkiye'nin.
Ama kimi bildireceğimizi bilemiyoruz.
Bize yardım eder misiniz?" dedi.
Nedir, dedim, pozisyon,
yani nereye aday bildirilecek,
akşamın saat 10'unu geçmiş yani bu saatte!
Dedi ki, "Birleşmiş Milletler'in
Uyuşturucu Kontrol Kurulu var.
13 kişiden oluşan bir kurul.
Seçimle kazanılıyor oradaki üyelikler
ve ülkeler aday gösteriyorlar,
biz de birini arıyoruz.
Tepem attı fena hâlde.
O anda dedim ki,
"Benden daha iyisi yok!"
"Peki," dedi adam.
Bunun üzerine ben öz geçmişimi faksladım.
İzleyen aylarda seçimlere girdim
ve de o kurulun 13 üyesinden birisi oldum,
2005-2010 arası orada çalıştım.
Kurulun başkanı da oldum,
kurulun ikinci kadın başkanıyım.
Yani 100 yıllık tarihinde,
benden önce 50'li yıllarda
bir Amerikalı kadın var.
Ondan sonra ben oldum.
Tabii ki o kurulun
ilk Türk başkanı da oldum.
Böylece bir telefonla,
bir hayat birdenbire beni
yurt dışında bir göreve,
hem de beş yıllık bir göreve de götürdü.
Aynı görevi şu anda da, tekrar
seçimleri kazandığım için yürütüyorum.
2017-2022 arası da yine
orada görev yapacağım.
Aslı Öymen, CNN Türk'ün
program müdürü,
o da bir gün bana dedi ki,
"Program yapar mısın?"
Televizyon programı!
Hiç hayatımda böyle
bir şeyi tabii ki bilmiyorum.
Bir üniversite hocasıyız.
Evet, tabii, bütün hayatımız
boyunca ders anlattık
ama televizyon programı
nasıl yapılır bilmiyoruz.
Bir tartışma programı istedi benden,
dedi ki, "Adına "Suç ve Delil" diyelim,
bir tartışma programı yap."
Hiç düşünmeden evet dedim.
Yıllarca CNN Türk'te Suç ve Delil
diye bir tartışma programı yaptım.
Benzeri bir programı daha sonra,
"Acayip İşler" diyerek
Habertürk'te yürüttüm.
Bu arada - biraz zor gözüküyor ama -
bu Türkiye'nin yetiştirdiği
en iyi yönetmenlerden bir tanesi,
yönetmen ve yapımcılardan
biri Abdullah Oğuz.
Abdullah Oğuz bana diyor ki yine böyle,
"Dizi yapar mısın?"
"Yaparım!" dedim ben de.
(Kahkahalar)
"Kanıt" yaptık, 100 bölüm yaptık.
Kanıt'ı yazdık, içine çıktık,
bir şeyler anlattık.
O anlattıklarımız hâlâ dinleniyor,
Kanıt bitti çoktan
ama bir televizyon kanalı
her gece iki bölümü gösteriyor.
Herhâlde 100. defa tekrar
gösteriyor, seyretmeyen kalmadı.
Anadolu'da dolaştığım zaman sesimden
tanıyorlar, başka bir şeyden değil.
Ama sesi duyunca "Kanıt" diyorlar.
Evet diyorum, o benim.
Önemli olmamakla beraber
şöyle küçük bir faydası var,
taksi şoförleri para almamaya çalışıyor.
Yani herhâlde çok önemsiyorlar,
ben zorla para veriyorum.
Şimdi bu da bir an ama bu da bir an,
bu da enteresan bir an;
çünkü "Acayip İşler" programını yaparken
ölü yıkama ile ilgili bir program yaptım.
Böyle ölülerle ilgili
ve bir gassal, bir imam,
bir adli tıp hocası
ve de resimde gördüğünüz
Profesör Doktor Nevzat Tarhan.
Ölüm konuşuyoruz, sadece.
İşte biri ölü yıkamayı anlatıyor,
öbürü ölüleri nasıl kestiğini anlatıyor,
diğeri nasıl dua ettiğini anlatıyor
ve yani, böyle biraz
tüyler ürpertici bir şey.
Zaten programın adı da "Acayip İşler."
Neyse program bitti, Nevzat Bey ile
biz orada ilk defa karşılaştık.
Daha önce tanımıyordum yani.
Kalkarken dedi ki, "Siz bana
danışman olur musunuz?"
"Olurum," dedim.
Üsküdar Üniversitesi'nin rektörüymüş,
biraz geç fark ettim onu,
nereye danışman olduğumu da.
Sempatik bir adam geldi bana.
Neyse, "Olur, olurum," dedim.
Orada bir danışman olarak başladım.
Kısa bir süre sonra, tabii baktı ki
burada iyi işler yapılabilir,
beni bir bölümün başkanlığına,
sonra rektör yardımcılığına getirdi.
Türkiye'de ilk defa dört yıllık adli
bilimler lisans eğitimi açabildim orada.
Başka hiçbir üniversitede yok.
Yani bu kriminal laboratuvarlarda
çalışacak olanları yetiştiren bir yer
ve buna benzer çok enteresan işler yaptık
ve nihayet de, onu da tabii tanıyorsunuz,
sevgili İlber Hocamız.
Onunla da --
Bir gün kendisi bana
telefon etti, dedi ki,
"Gel senle program yapalım."
Soramadım bile ne programı yapacağız diye,
o kadar sevdiğim bir insan
yani gördüğünüz zaman.
"Yapalım hoca," dedim.
"Gel Zaman, Git Zaman" diyerekten,
bu sefer de NTV'de epey
uzun süren bir program yaptık.
O tarih anlattı, ben adli bilimleri.
Kralları nasıl öldürdüklerini anlattık,
bir taraftan aşkları anlattık vesaire.
Kadınların nasıl daha iyi
birer katil olduğunu anlattık.
Onlar biliyorsunuz
ellerini kana bulamazlar.
Hep başka birilerini bulurlar
işlerini yaptırabilmek için.
Efendim, sevgililer gününüz kutlu olsun.
Benden size bu kadar.
Çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)